hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be going over the
age-old
question who has it harder in dating
men or women now before i begin
the video do not forget to like comment
and subscribe i'm really trying to hit
that 15
000 subscribers this week so if you guys
could hit that subscribe button i'd
really
really appreciate it i'm trying to move
out of my parents house i really am
my mom's getting so annoyed with me like
she wants me out of here um
okay though so who has it harder
in dating men or women now
i think the problem is that when people
talk about this argument
they imagine they're born a hot girl
okay or they're born
a hot guy now let's take the other side
of the argument
let's say you're born an ugly girl and
an
ugly guy
i think undoubtedly women have it
harder because if you are born an
unattractive girl there is
literally nothing you can do like you
can't change your face right but as a
guy
okay hugh hefner was he really that
attractive of a guy
i mean he was just always old when i
knew him so i actually have no idea what
he looked like
young but like even dave portnoy he's
not that tall
but they both had women out the wazoo
because okay because as a guy
let's say you have a bad you're born
like five five
not attractive heavy you can go to the
gym get a good job
work really hard at that job and at
first you probably
you're not gonna get any life's tough
but like by the time you're 35
like you have something to look forward
to where a woman
if you're born an unattractive woman
like
one you probably don't have that many
options and two like
there's nothing you can do like you
can't change it
and the options that you do have like
like you can't improve is what i'm
saying like you're born you're born with
what you're born with and you're [ __ ]
out of luck if you didn't get the right
cards
with a guy you can change it so
that is why in my opinion i think dating
is easier for
men than women but let me know in the
comments if you agree with me if you
disagree with me
and what video should i do next like
what would you like to hear me
comment on i'll talk to you guys later
bye